Tasha:这怎么可能呢
Tasha: That's impossible.
Tasha:就塞一半呗
Tasha: Just stuff it halfway.
其他人:藏这空调扇叶里
Others: Hide it in the air conditioner's fan blades.
Lucia: 好他在上面那个盖一打开好了
Lucia: Okay, once you open the cover on top, it's good.
其他人：藏完了
Others: All hidden.
Alice:还有给你
Alice: Here's more for you.
Alice:还藏吗来
Alice: Still hiding? Come on.
其他人:来好
Others: Come on, okay.
其他人:发挥我的想象力
Others: Use your imagination.
Lucia: 哎呀镜子这会掉
Lucia: Oh no, the mirror might fall.
其他人:这不是藏的是贴的
Others: This isn't hiding, it's sticking.
Lucia: 可恶哈哈
Lucia: Darn it, haha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake:贴上去的
Jake: It's stuck on.
Alice:昨天昨天藏在这一个
Alice: Yesterday, we hid one here.
Lucia: 希望他别掉到后面
Lucia: Hope it doesn't fall behind.
Lucia: 拿不出来了就行
Lucia: If it gets stuck, that's it.
Jake:哦这个还挺挺看到
Jake: Oh, this one is quite visible.
Jake:挺容易看到的
Jake: It's pretty easy to see.
Lucia: 那就下面
Lucia: Then put it lower.
Alice:可以拿个胶带这样反粘着
Alice: You can use tape and stick it in reverse.
Lucia: 哎呀真掉进去了
Lucia: Oh no, it really fell in.
Jake:这个不好
Jake: This isn't good.
Lucia: 嗯哎我的美人指到了
Lucia: Hmm, oh, my finger reached it.
Jake:这好夹了
Jake: This is stuck.
Jake:这肯定有缝
Jake: There must be a gap.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Alice:不太好夹吧
Alice: It's hard to clamp, isn't it?
Jake:肯定很有缝吧
Jake: There must be a gap.
Jake:没有缝吧
Jake: No gap?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake:这么结实
Jake: So sturdy.
Jake:这东西
Jake: This thing...
其他人:我好像我藏的地方藏的挺好
Others: I think the place I hid it is pretty good.
Lucia: 哎不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 你要出去吗
Lucia: Do you need to go out?
其他人：我不出去
Others: I'm not going out.
其他人：我在想吃酸辣
Others: I'm thinking of eating something spicy and sour.
Lucia: 呃那我就把这关上了
Lucia: Uh, then I'll just close this.
Lucia: 我们光放大厅吗
Lucia: Are we just putting it in the hall?
Lucia: 是不是院子也可以放
Lucia: Or can we put it in the yard too?
Alice:甜品台底下放一个
Alice: Put one under the dessert table.
Lucia: 这有这个
Lucia: There's this.
Lucia: 大家要想粘也可以用它粘一下
Lucia: If anyone wants to stick something, they can use this to stick it.
Lucia: 就是美纹纸可信
Lucia: This masking tape is reliable.
Lucia: 今天要用的那个哦
Lucia: We're using this today.
Alice:可以给我一卷吗
Alice: Can you give me a roll?
Jake:能稍微稍微没那么难找一些
Jake: Can it be a little easier to find?
Lucia: 没问题
Lucia: No problem.
Alice:古希拉掌管交代的神
Alice: The god in charge in ancient Greece...
Lucia: 古希腊掌管古希腊掌管美纹纸的神
Lucia: The god in charge of masking tape in ancient Greece.
Lucia: 哈哈要吗
Lucia: Haha, want it?
Lucia: 给你哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Here you go, oh my!
Alice:没有仪式感一点
Alice: It doesn't have any sense of ceremony.
Lucia: 没有哎呦妈呀哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, haha.
其他人:就把我藏在那个洗衣机上
Others: Just hide me on the washing machine.
其他人:洗衣机上OK
Others: On the washing machine, OK.
Lucia: 哈不用谢
Lucia: Haha, you're welcome.
Lucia: 哈哈这个我应该也就用一卷
Lucia: Haha, I might just use one roll.
其他人:你说啊洗衣机上
Others: You mean on the washing machine?
Lucia: 可能就差不多了
Lucia: That should be enough.
Lucia: 他是就是一买就是五卷
Lucia: He always buys five rolls at a time.
Lucia: 但是它很便宜好像才8毛钱
Lucia: But it's very cheap, like 8 cents.
Lucia: 还是多少钱
Lucia: Or how much?
Alice:一共吗还是一卷
Alice: Altogether or per roll?
Lucia: 一共
Lucia: Altogether.
Lucia: 是不是很神奇
Lucia: Isn't it amazing?
Alice:确实
Alice: It really is.
Lucia: 而且我们就剪短用一下
Lucia: And we just cut short pieces to use.
Lucia: 我觉得应该也是能用的了的
Lucia: I think it should be enough.
Lucia: 但我找到了一大包
Lucia: But I found a big pack.
其他人：我把这一拿就拿出来了
Others: I just took it out.
Shure: 谜底就在谜面上
Shure: The answer is in the riddle.
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
其他人:你哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:这个很圆这个
Jake: This is really round, this one.
Shure: 这呢确实特别像那什么
Shure: This one really looks like, you know.
Lucia: 花瓶啊底下有一个丫鬟
Lucia: A vase, with a maid underneath.
Alice:那草底下能藏吗
Alice: Can it be hidden under the grass?
其他人：你这个新音响能拆开吗
Others: Can you open this new speaker?
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Lucia: 草地下我藏了一个
Lucia: I hid one under the grass.
Lucia: 你有看到吗
Lucia: Did you see it?
Alice:没有哦看
Alice: No, look.
Lucia:  哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:看到了
Alice: I saw it.
Lucia: 看到了绿色的
Lucia: Saw the green one.
Lucia: 这还有
Lucia: There's more here.
Alice:这个底下有吗
Alice: Is there anything under this?
Lucia: 这个底下好像没有
Lucia: Doesn't seem like there's anything under this one.
Lucia: 但这音箱明天会放在这吗
Lucia: But will the speaker be here tomorrow?
Lucia: 有可能会放嗯
Lucia: It might be, yeah.
Jake:有可能会挪对
Jake: It might be moved, yeah.
Shure: 有意思
Shure: Interesting.
Jake:有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Alice:有意思
Alice: Interesting.
Jake:烤箱能烤好吗我去
Jake: Can the oven bake it properly, oh man.
Lucia: 院子里能放吗
Lucia: Can it be placed in the yard?
Jake:院子可以放
Jake: It can be placed in the yard.
Alice:这个应该没了
Alice: This one should be done.
Alice:不是这个
Alice: Not this one.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia: 你的也灭了
Lucia: Yours is off too.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 我的还亮着
Lucia: Mine is still on.
Lucia: 耶
Lucia: Yay.
Lucia: 放冰箱里
Lucia: Put it in the fridge.
Shure: 是什么意思
Shure: What does that mean?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
其他人：就是你随便训了个模型啊
Others: It just means you trained a random model.
Lucia: 放哪呢
Lucia: Where should we put it?
其他人：这模型呢
Others: What about this model?
其他人： 测试集完全没见了
Others: The test set is completely gone.
其他人：但他就会
Others: But he can still do it.
其他人：就是第一个啊
Others: It's the first one.
Lucia: 外面感觉容易被风吹走
Lucia: It feels like it could easily be blown away outside.
Alice:充电没有用电快
Alice: Charging isn't as fast as using power.
其他人：非常好的散发器
Others: It's a very good disperser.
Lucia: 放在这烤箱下面
Lucia: Put it under this oven.
Jake:这个我们先导播
Jake: Let's broadcast this first.
Jake:充会电导播数据然后过
Jake: Charge it a bit and then broadcast the data.
Jake:过半个小时把那个QA给搞了一下
Jake: After half an hour, let's deal with that QA.
Jake:结束了
Jake: It's over.
Jake:然后这个明天就囤着
Jake: Then we'll store this for tomorrow.
Jake:是吧蛋挞不要吃掉
Jake: Don't eat the egg tarts, okay?
Jake:那就一边讨论吃的
Jake: Let's discuss food while eating egg tarts.
Jake:一边吃蛋挞
Jake: And eat egg tarts.
Tasha: 只有这个是留着的
Tasha: Only this one is saved.
Jake:就这些都得吃掉
Jake: All of these need to be eaten.
Alice:充电宝给你吗
Alice: Do you want the power bank?
Jake:呃都都给我
Jake: Uh, give them all to me.
Jake:呃快活了
Jake: Uh, feeling good.
Lucia: 充电宝我刚刚已经摘下来了
Lucia: I just took off the power bank.
Lucia: 这是我吗
Lucia: Is this mine?
Shure: 才4下就不行了谢云卓
Shure: It's only been 4 times and it's already not working, Xie Yunzhuo.
Shure: 这这顶上撒啥的
Shure: What's sprinkled on top of this?
Jake:眼睛直接给我
Jake: Just give me the eyes directly.
Lucia: 哎等一下
Lucia: Hey, wait a moment.
Lucia: 眼镜我是不是要对停一下然后
Lucia: Should I stop to adjust the glasses?
Shure: 啊眼镜我也要拿下来
Shure: Ah, I need to take off the glasses too.
Jake:是吗你给给我吧好
Jake: Really? Give them to me, okay.
Lucia: 等一下哦
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Katrina: 大概需要多久
Katrina: How long will it take approximately?